hello and welcome to the very first
episode of the corridor digital podcast
thank you so much for being here I'm
super excited about this we've put a
bunch of work into this room we've got a
bunch of great guests in here and spend
months in the making and we're finally
here the episodes are live this first
episode is with Jake Roper the host and
producer of vsauce3 he sat down with Ren
and I we had a great conversation we
talked about his love for science and
movies we talked about beam and his
experiences over there we talked about
how Vsauce used to be owned by Google
and then became its own company and
lastly we talked about his stage three
cancer which he was recently cleared
from last year so some pretty powerful
stuff he's a great guy sit back and
enjoy the conversation and if you
haven't subscribed yet I would
definitely recommend it Jake Roper the
host and producer of vsauce3 3.5 million
subscribers a fantastic Channel there is
nothing like it on YouTube in fact
there's nothing like it at all I think
that's very nice of you well it's true
Ren give me compliments now and there's
there's is this blending science it's
this blend of movies and you kind of
just go through it like you're on a
little adventure yeah and so I want to I
want to talk about could you survive the
movies but before before we get into
that I want to hear a little bit about
why science why movies okay
so I've always loved filmmaking I've
always wanted to be a director and I
think for some reason I just kind of
gravitated towards science as being the
genre of film that I made or that's so
much the John Moores liked the topic and
then the genre could be anything right
um one of the things I love about film
tangent is that it allows you to for at
least a brief amount of time be at an
hour and a half thirty minutes five
minutes to be in control of somebody's
emotions which i think is so interesting
yeah you know cuz like I don't know
about you guys run cries a lot but like
I don't usually cry that often baby boy
movie like the first ten minutes of up
you just start crying and like that kind
of power the fact that something that
you're watching can do that to you I
think is so curious
so interesting and I wanted to be a part
of that yeah that's where like my love
for filmmaking came through and also I
think a little bit of the psychology so
when it comes to where did this marriage
come from of science and film it seemed
to me when I started doing Vsauce that I
didn't just have to be a talking head
with a black background like talking to
camera throwing to like b-roll or
archival footage it could actually feel
like an adventure that we were on there
could be a story to help explain and
express what we're trying to talk about
because as you said like one thing I
really care about is making it feel like
an adventure making it feel like an
experience that we're going on together
yeah
is something that's really key to me
because it keeps it exciting for myself
but hopefully keeps it exciting for the
audience or even if you're not that it
like I don't really care about the
square-cube law
well let's express it in a way where it
feels really exciting and really big
know wow I just wanted this cool journey
and now I know about all these different
things right so yeah yeah were you
interested in science as a kid mm-hmm I
was a that was a little tinkerer okay
building things as a kid did you Legos
or connects Legos I didn't have
connected money sorry oh my god build a
roller coaster and I was like I built
Jurassic Nordic castle well okay Richie
Rich with your connects and money
connects pass me my wine flask all the
time I drink my connects wine flask with
the pinky out yes my Capri Sun is
delicious 40 degrees Fahrenheit anyway
yeah I was related I love building
things like I remember when I was 11 I
built my very first computer really yeah
like a desktop computer yo yeah I went
to compusa back when they existed Wow
bought all the parts it was an AMD
processor man it was dope yeah I didn't
build my first computer ty was like 20 I
was 27 well I mean if it makes you guys
feel any better I was 11 when you guys
were like 20 or so it was about like the
same time yes that's right cuz I'm so
you don't you're like what 20 years old
right now my man
I've always been curious about how
things work in putting things together
and also just like I think I don't know
if physics has always been interesting
to me mm-hmm
cuz I just think it's I don't know it's
not super intuitive but when you
understand the concept of something like
oh now that makes sense like that like
force I get it yeah I think that laws of
the universe yeah everything I buy
everything by but it'll bides buy it so
I've been talking so much like the dude
abides yes that's a movie reference all
my young kids to a film called The Big
Lebowski
almost blank
for some reason I was gonna say deuce
Bigalow male gigolo I don't know why
that's the different movie has a much
different film yeah maybe they say the
dude abides in there ii don't think
video is good so can we get a
verification anyway I don't even know
we're talking about science as a science
as a kid and you got so you your current
like I guess channel basically revolves
around merging filmmaking with science
and trying to make a a good fun
interesting like a good time right some
someone is entertained but they also
learned something along the way
hopefully yeah you said it much more
clearly than I did you did I hear you're
right rim oh well thank you're a pro so
yeah you uh you spent how many months
working on this can you survive Mad Max
uh I mean in actual pre-production until
we finished it it was about five to six
months but I've been working on like I
pitched it to YouTube in like May of
last year and then it took us until May
of this year to actually get into
pre-production and this is a YouTube
original show which means everyone can
watch it for free right now yeah that
was some that was very important to me
like at the end of the day us creators
don't have a say and if it gets if it's
original or premium which is behind the
paywall but I was very adamant in it
being original by just bugging them
every single week and luckily by the end
they were like I remember we had just
did our picture lock on the on the video
like it was done we were we had already
finished like color correcting at
everything and they were like hey good
news it's gonna be free to watch so now
you need to go back in and make five
commercial breaks we're like oh lost
like our editor and all that stuff and
then like a few hours later like I never
mind you just need what's gonna do a
commercial the beginning in the end
oh nice you don't have to change
anything but I was so excited about that
cuz you know I think I want to make
videos and the reason I went to youtube
is so everyone can watch them yeah
there's no like barrier to entry it's
not like a ride at Disneyland you can be
any height and ride the ride and that's
what's important to me
yeah is I if I if I made something in
like only a hundred thousand people
could possibly watch it that seems less
rewarding to me than being able to have
anyone watch it so that was a very key
part to me so yeah luckily as you to
original and if I get to make more
they'll all be a youtube originals so
that well hopefully my dream is knock on
wood that this wall this is all I'm
gonna make it's just like eight to ten
episodes a year of could you spy the
movies and then that's it are you in the
process of pitching the next slate of
episodes so we did about a month or two
ago I sent the deck of like what I saw
for the season um we're waiting to hear
back still probably won't know anything
until next year which is a bummer but
we're just two months away yeah I mean
some of them I'll just give you a little
tease yeah taste of some of the ones
that I pitched were like Blade Runner I
would love to do Blade II would be
visually amazing like imagine the score
for that yeah yeah but also there's so
many interesting topics that we can talk
about we can kind of talk about you know
actually uploading one's consciousness
to a being I know this a little bit
different there because it's artificial
beings that do have consciousness but I
think talking about that like the
singularity all these different ideas
are really curious to me and really
interesting to me because one of my
favorite topics is always what makes you
you like if you did and again this
doesn't only have an Blade Runner but if
you were able to like put your
consciousness into a computer is that
computer human like what is it that
makes you a human being if you lose all
your arms and legs you're still a person
right so right and do you have to lose
enough to no longer be human and like
what is it that makes us human so I
really want to explore that it's a very
philosophical topic
yes it's psychological its philosophical
its theological even yeah we got all the
logicals um so I want to do that back to
the future which would be dope yes that
would be sweet alien I really want to do
Indiana Jones I really want to do so
there's some things in there that I
would love to make okay so you spent the
last several years basically just making
science short videos like five minutes
long sometimes a little longer sometimes
a little less
and so it seems like you're kind of done
with that stage of your career like
you're kind of like over just making
short videos and you want to make more
of this long-term content so you're
saying you want to make like 8 X 8
half-hour episodes a year and just do
that for the next several years matter
that's that would be enjoyable for me I
mean I think there's actually a thing
that I I felt a lot when I started
making YouTube videos as I felt like
they had to be short like I couldn't be
engaging or interesting or have enough
information to make a 10 minute or 15
minute video well yeah and it was like
behind the whole mindset of YouTube is
you know short attention span you gotta
grab in the first 10 seconds and you
can't have a video be longer than a few
minutes otherwise they're gone they're
never coming back what I've learned is
if you know as long as it's interesting
and you can keep it interesting then it
should be as long as it needs to be to
tell a story you're trying to tell
totally
and you're never just shorten it
artificially because like oh I think if
it's three minutes we'll do better it's
like no if it's a story that takes ten
minutes to say then say it in ten
minutes
if it only takes three minutes but
you're stretching it to ten minutes then
maybe don't do that so wait like The
Hobbit like The Hobbit
I actually just watched a really great
fan at it like maple films fan it was
all three Hobbit films condensed into
four hours and they cut out everything
that wasn't in the books it was great
yeah I've heard about that yeah and that
seems like such a better idea for The
Hobbit films because that was my main
complaint is that there it was just like
I didn't mind so much it being split
into three films III minded that there
was so much in each film that I just
didn't care about and just didn't feel
necessary so hearing that like there's a
fan of that really just trimmed out all
the fat even though sometimes I'm kind
of iffy on fan edits because you have an
amateur coming in just slicing apart at
professionals yeah work and so like
there's some I don't know complications
when it comes to like doing that I would
say about this one it if I didn't know
as a fan of it I have no idea like they
have the music transition like the edits
go so well that like you can't really
tell at all that it was sliced together
after the fact so yeah so you're saying
it's well done which is yeah right and
so like I did a storyboard change topics
out but last we got a fun little week
for myself and I watched The Hobbit fan
edit before our version and then I
followed it up with Fellowship of the
Ring extended edition to towers in
addition then returned the Kingston
edition and that was
really cool cuz like in in one go not in
one night like across in a week okay I
got so cool because you you know in the
hobbit like Oh Bilbo gets the chainmail
thing and he gets like his sword and
then we see that all in like the
fellowship and so for like take this
chainmail that I got like how everybody
got that
and all these little things happening
like okay I get it do you want to tie
some of that through some of your
content like a little bit more of a
narrative in in that sense or I do I
mean I've made like for some of my
videos I've made semi sequels to them or
like I made one called could you have a
fall out and then a year later I
followed it up with what if the world
ended and in that in my own like
universe those movies happen after each
other yeah but I'm the same character so
like I started to be like oh I haven't
seen you in a while I haven't seen you
since the bombs dropped it's like oh
that was the same character from there
right so I trying to have them in that I
made a third movie in that little
trilogy which was called a are you a
parasite which was kind of like my
characters survived the apocalypse and
now we're in this like barren winter
wasteland
so I try and do that we're like there is
a through-line but again even with the
Mad Max video I try and make them or if
you had never even seen the movie or
don't really know the previous context
it still makes sense to you yeah yeah I
think that's that's why I wanted to
bring that topic up first because I
think in a way you've kind of stumbled
on an infinite format in a way which is
very good very good job good job thanks
god it's really hard to do not a lot of
people know how to do it but just with
the ability to draw on things like what
our vampire is and Blade Runner and
uploading consciousness and getting all
that from one world and then applying
that to actually what we know about
science I mean you can kind of do that
across anything and that's I think
what's fascinating about it
yeah I mean that's what makes it really
exciting to me I never wanted to be one
of those creators or filmmakers whatever
we want to classify ourselves as that
makes the same thing over and over again
because at the end of the day it is kind
of the same thing but it's expressed
differently yeah and that's what's
important to me and you explore
different topics within those things
yeah the format is the same but it's
you know you're exploring completely
different topics yeah the way I'd like
to think about it is the beginning in
the end are always the same it always
starts with Vsauce I'm Jake and then it
always ends with and as always thanks
for watching everything in between those
two points can be whatever I want as
long as it leads to that final area
right and that's because that's kind of
like the Vsauce format is that yeah are
you holding to that because that's a
Vsauce thing I hold to it mainly because
it allows me to focus better like I need
some constraints to make something if I
have no constraints I don't know what to
make yet I hear you yeah like if
somebody's like hey Jake here's $10,000
make whatever you wanna be like oh I
don't know what to make yeah so I need
those things like okay it has to be
science focused great that's this pillar
that I can stick to yeah it has to start
an end with these like phrases great
that's a pillar that I can stick to so I
need those things to help control my
creativity and focus me into actually
coming up with ideas yeah that makes
sense okay I think that's great I'm
gonna transition now hard transition you
know topic tell me about beam Oh beam
it's beam time and being time all I know
here's all here's what I know
yeah give me the gossip I'm I'm the
gossip guy I was on YouTube the other
day and I was watching Jake ropers
channel and I was watching Casey
neistat's channel and all of a sudden
you guys were like hey we're doing beam
and then and then beam went under so
what what I don't know and I think what
people would like to know is what
happened mm why is it no longer why are
you no longer involved wise you know
well it's a preface should we preface
this a little bit like being for those
of you who don't know beam was the
company started by Casey Neistat after
they were bought by CNN
so her beam was those knee we don't even
know this is why we need to ask yeah let
me go back so Ben was an app created by
Casey Neistat that's it and his partner
on the project Matt Hackett who's like a
brilliant engineer and manager okay um
so they started beam as the social media
app and the app was I mean I still have
it on my phone doesn't work anymore but
the first step was kind of like snapchat
where you could record like five seconds
of your life and then we just upload it
but what made it interesting is that you
couldn't actually have the screen active
you couldn't look at it cuz like on
snapchat or not really living you're
like okay I gotta get this framed right
this was the yeah you hold your phone up
against your chest the screens right
yeah
and then it records and you can't watch
back what you just did it automatically
then uploads it and that was the premise
of beam it's be me right like you're
actually just showing what you're
experiencing and there's no editing or
you can't redo it once you film it it's
gone it's done ah okay so that was the
app the crea
and then CNN bought the company not so
much for the app ended up killing the
app but they bought it for like people
like Casey Matt the tech team cuz you
nerd net you TiVo Cena and really wanted
to get into YouTube and like focus on
digital content and how to get a younger
audience on to their platform so that's
why they bought the company and then
after buying it Casey called me cuz a
little fun sir I've known Casey for like
nine years it was about to ask like huh
like your guys's relationship goes far
back before beam and yeah it's like he's
like looking on YouTube who should I
hire to help run this company like oh
this guy looks cool no you guys have a
previous relationship your cuts I don't
often I nor ten years because I think
when I was 21 I first start working for
him like I edited this Dockers
documentary for him that him and his
friend Oscar who is now like a wonderful
movie producer we're making and they
hired me to edit the thing Dockers like
the pants yeah they did a they'd give me
like two seconds on that because Casey
you know he always would make these
branded pieces that were didn't have
anything to do with the brand like his
Nike ones his most famous one where it's
just like they gave me a bunch of money
and I spend it on traveling around the
world with my friend Oscar right yeah or
like his do what you can't campaign for
Samsung it's not about the phone right
it's about the idea of what the phone
could be and that's like how he does
advertising which I love right so what
doctors the documentary was called an
emasculating truth and was about like
what it means to be a man so and like
doctors no one's wearing Dockers like I
don't even know what their engagement
was but yeah so we did that and it's
like so there's like a photo of me of
little 20 21 year old Jake on his
Polaroid wall in his office this little
photo of I always look at it when I'm
there like huh look at me I'm terrible
at him and we also did work at this
television ever called plum TV together
where he would make like these ad
packages and stuff for him and I was
just a producer there and that was
before he did his HBO show that was
the HBO show yeah so actually the guy
Tom Scott who created different than the
youtuber Tom Scott top this Tom Scott
created Nantucket nectars and when he
sold that company he then created plum
TV which was this television network
you went from juice to TV juice to TV
and so he kind of like found kcl so they
found a lot of interesting people like
super Marche like Henry juiced
who did catfish Casey Neistat myself
like we all started at Plum and then
Casey's TV show actually was helped by
Tom Scott cuz he started then working
with Casey it was like oh it's like do
movies it's tough so they didn't movie
cuz like daddy longlegs together that I
think Casey like executive produced and
Tom Scott executive produced and then
they all said the HBO show that Casey
had with his brother van so yeah so I
was like 21 just sitting in the
Chinatown office like van had one side
at the time in case he had the other
side and I were just like edit so anyway
I know Casey for a long time and that's
a swords always been friends and so yeah
when this opportunity came up he called
me he's like you're the only person I
can think that can do this like we need
to make a news network
on YouTube but yet even told me that yet
he was like I have this cool opportunity
want to talk to you about flat in New
York like sweet so I've like flew out a
few days later met him and Matt Hackett
and a guy from CNN where did it go from
be me don't show you can't see the
screen
yeah to news network so it was this
multi-pronged idea where we saw beam as
being beam news beam tech and then beam
productions and beam tech would still be
the same tech team and they'd be
focusing on two products one was called
beam panels was actually did launch and
the whole idea which I really did love
cuz I I mean like most people you get
sick of news and especially the way that
news is presented it feels very
disingenuous and it doesn't yeah I'm not
accessible to me right the point of
being panels was that we would ask a
question about something that was
happening and then you the user would
upload your own thing so instead of a
Talking Heads show of like 10 different
people that you don't know that don't
represent you it'd be you I mean like
here's what I think about this topic and
then people could respond to your topic
and just be like a whole discussion that
you're having through 30 second videos
all right that was the first product the
second one was called beam wire that one
never launched I don't even know if most
people know it it was ever in existence
but that was a really cool and to were
seeing well the thing we liked about CNN
was
endless resources that we capitalize on
one of the resources that they have live
streams from every single like press
conference every single like embassy
everything we could sort those and like
allow you to access every single live
feed so you would be the one who chooses
what news you want to watch so that was
the app we were creating for that and it
also had this really wonderful facial
recognition recognition algorithm so it
was like someone important speaking it
would tell you like oh this person
speaking outside the Turkish embassy you
click on it oh it's that person would
give you a whole bio of them so instead
of getting like you do when you normally
turn on CNN getting the feed that's
local to you you could get any feed that
there yeah and also it's not an curated
by anyone there there could be no bias
because you were watching it with your
own eyes not through a filter of
somebody else's right and that was kind
of the idea behind it is that you choose
the news that you want to digest and you
digest it exactly how you want no one
else is cutting it up for you and
serving it to you mmm so when you fly
out to New York to talk to Casey and
Matt like how do they pitch this to you
like what were they wanting to hire you
for they weren't sure at the moment they
were like we just want you to run either
like be the creative director of beam or
be the director of production I kind of
was both so like I'd sit in with Casey
and Matt unlike what's the branding
gonna look like how do we actually show
things like when we have text on screen
like what does that look like so I was
in charge of like all that kind of stuff
Oh like what does it look and feel the
show the issue that we ran into is we
didn't figure out the show yet like I
think one of the best videos we made was
when I first got there I was there for
like a week and I had to fly back to LA
because I hadn't gotten a place in New
York yet Casey and I just filmed a video
about hacking because he had just gotten
hacked and so I was like oh I know about
this cool device called the pineapple
which allows you to basically spoof
Wi-Fi networks so you can create a Wi-Fi
network me like free Wi-Fi and then
people connect to it then we get
everyone's access so we went to a
Starbuck we got one of the engineers at
Beam and we went to the Starbucks across
the street and the engineer and I sat in
a corner created a fake network and then
Casey like went up to the counter
ordered a coffee and then like joined
free Wi-Fi and we could see everything
he did he like logged into his Chase
account and we could see like his
username and his password oh wow we
could see everything he was doing you
know so easy this hundred dollar device
we bought off the internet and that's
kind of what the images of this episode
was and we made it we only half made it
because and I had to leave and then
Casey
started his vlog again cuz I remember
but after the company got bought he
stopped vlogging he was like done
vlogging he's just gonna focus on beam
they started vlogging again we ended up
not finishing that episode and then so
the long story short that's super
interesting there's a half made episode
out there somewhere yeah my miracle
it was really cool that like I because
also this is back like he had that hack
then there was that huge data breach
I think the Equifax thing like happened
at the same time yeah so was kind about
how not secure you are and that was kind
of the whole conceit of the episode and
that's kind of what we had envisioned
the show would be like it would be kind
of like this investigative journalism
but still in the style that Casey and I
have where it feels homemade but also
like high quality so how would people
how would the consumer access these
multi pronged parts of the network of
beam what was the intent there so the
antennas we have beam news which should
be the front-facing YouTube channel that
would then feed to the apps like people
hopefully find the apps organically
visible apps but also like one idea we
tried doing and we stopped by the end
but we would try and include beam panels
participants in a topic so we know we
know that we're making a video about
like electric vehicles let's ask a
question on panels on electric vehicles
and then we'd include those voices in
the episode so that was trying to drive
traffic from both things then we had
beam productions
which was meant to be the thing that
actually generated revenue and that was
like okay we have a great connection
with Samsung let's make all their
commercials we just have like Casey and
Jake let's make documentaries and that
was the the main thing that I was sold
on because the news thing I was like
okay this could be interesting and I
want to challenge myself see if I can do
it but the whole point was casein I do
news for three to six months and then
that thing runs itself we don't have to
touch it anymore and then we focus on
being productions where my whole goal I
remember like sitting with them and
talking to them what I really wanted to
make I was like let's be the first
YouTube channel to get nominated for an
Academy Award I was like I want to make
a mini documentary that gets nominated
for like best mini docket the Academy
Awards how do we do that
and that was like one of my big pushes
and like everyone was super excited
about it we never got there well that's
kind of what casein I had focused on we
were working on like a YouTube original
show that'd be a documentary series
about youtubers but down in the style of
like you know
I wore thin blue line where someone
talking directly to camera and then we
do these beautiful recreations that are
cinematic to express what they're
talking about right but we didn't get to
that point huh now anyone who's familiar
with Casey Neistat or or being knows
that it eventually did get shut down
what led to the eventual shutdown of the
company like I know there are lots of
different factors involved can you talk
about that he was the summary yeah there
was a few things that led to it because
at the end of the day you know even
though we did have which I'm very
grateful for it CNN did give us complete
control over doing anything we wanted to
at the end of the day they were our
bosses and they had a different vision
for it than what we did you know
originally we were given a very long
runway of three years to figure out what
we wanted to do and it takes time like I
think creating something new like you
have people like philip defranco who
make incredible news content on youtube
yeah we wanted to create something
different in new and exciting that
wasn't like Phil that wasn't like vice
and it takes time yeah and we finally I
think found our footing about a month or
two before they shut us down but the
reason that led to it there was a few
factors one was that they were planning
on this merger between Time Warner and
AT&T the merger got killed and the
Department of Justice killed it they
weren't able to do it so they had
factored all of their budgets and all
the things for that since they didn't
have that happen they then had to lay
off a lot of people and like adjust
their budgets so that then lowered our
budget to such a degree that it didn't
really make sense to keep it separate
from Cena anymore so the way we're gonna
roll it up into CNN Casey at this point
kind of wanted to do stuff other things
and he like he didn't like having to
work with a bunch of people like he's a
very independent person which I think
he's a lone wolf what's most creators I
mean the reason that we do is cuz like I
can edit it I can shoot it myself I can
write it myself
right it makes it person and I think and
I understood his frustration with
working with a bunch of people it can be
frustrating because again we were trying
to figure out what the show is going to
be and in that period we didn't know how
to run a news business so we leaned on
CNN seen it was like you have to hire
like these eight people that do these
eight jobs like okay then we had them
and we didn't know what to do with them
cuz then what we're still trying to
figure what the show is but now we have
all these people that need to do stuff
so I think there was just a lot of
pressure there but the main issue was
just the merger didn't happen then when
that didn't like when I went down case
it was like ABS do
my vlog and working other projects Matt
Hackett was like I'll just do other
stuff too I don't care and I had another
job here so that's fine I don't feel
like working for CNN proper all this so
where did you where where along the line
did you become this two-state citizen
where where yeah you're like living in
New York and you're living in Los
Angeles and I mean where are you from
so originally I was born in Washington
DC grew up for the first years of my
life in Virginia and then moved to
Colorado and grew up in Colorado from
like 8 to 18 where we're in Colorado
Evergreen Colorado it's a wonderful
mountain town I would highly recommend
going is it near Denver or is it it's
like 3 miles outside of Denver ok it's
in like the foothills yeah but it's
really cool I loved growing up there and
then I lived in New York for about 11
years and then moved to LA and then live
in LA for a year and then move half to
New York and a half to LA for a year and
then back in LA full time cuz I only met
you once when you were living in New
York
yeah and that was when we did the
superheroes for this game yeah yeah that
was our first color that's not your
first directing one that was their first
video so good thank you that video did
well it did me well yes you got you got
your face nice yeah brutally beaten to
death I do die cuz I'm like as I say a
line or something and they like my hand
it was the master ball comes out yeah
yeah that was fun yeah but I think it
actually this a fun fact little IMDB
trivia for you at home
the only reason I was cast in that video
is because I already owned most of the
outfit I think reason we cast you and
that was kids you got Ash Ketchum the
only reason you're the first guest on
the podcast is cuz you're across the
street it all makes sense it's fine yeah
that's okay yeah and then and then you
came down to this street and you got
your office here in 2016
yeah 2016 because that's when Vsauce
became independent from Google yeah so
can you talk about that real quick cuz I
don't think most people realize all
vsauce channels were google
I do for the longest time no idea like
you guys weren't making ad revenue from
your videos you guys had salaries at gun
GU money yeah that's sweet sweet gonna
give you money um yeah so basically
YouTube acquired a company or Google
acquired a company to has 11 called next
new networks and next new networks was
an MCN I don't know why Google chose
that MCN to buy but they bought him and
that's basically right the acquisition
is when I came on board because now they
had this department that could like make
content and also were creators
understood of creators thought the
reason they acquired it was mainly to
learn like they had creators and they
even have to look at you guys and like
from what from a balcony and watch you
like what they do yeah that's thing like
we would work like part of my job was
working with product and like UX and all
these different departments and telling
them how I use the platform as a creator
okay and then also they could do
experiments with us since our channels
didn't have to make money since we were
just employees there right I remember
like when um gosh before was end cards
what was the thing is like we tested
those out we test all these different
features like we'd really go heavily in
playlists which is light lean backs were
a thing that Michael created yeah
because it didn't matter if our videos
failed or not we just were experimenting
so we were we were literally called lab
channels because we were just a lab we
would be experimenting with different
parts of the platform that maybe never
even saw the light of day but we play
with them and see how they worked then
it became a success channel started
doing really well so as if you saw
started getting bigger and bigger we
started doing less and less actual work
so like my job because when I first art
working there I was doing Space Lab up
is also managing the YouTube New York
space like booking people like helping
them set up their gear all that stuff
and then I was also helping Michael with
Vsauce like editing dogs and stuff and
then as I said dogs
explain what a dong is real clear a dong
is something you can do online now guys
it's a dog
we have a whole channel YouTube channels
like just a joke that Michael had from
Vsauce when he's just like haha funny
I'm just gonna make this act
a bathroom in New York City somewhere
and everything dongs and this and that
has since become like its own
fully-fledged channel like the dong
Channel which is really cool because you
watch this a few minutes long it has all
these different like things you can go
do online now guys okay back to uh so
yes yes I reckon we're all there Michael
then transferred to the London office I
think at 2013 to 12 2012 maybe gentle
yet maybe 2012 any 2012 he transferred
to there Kevin moved to LA to work out
of the LA YouTube space and I was just
in New York by myself and the trails
kept growing growing so we just started
doing Vsauce because that was very
valuable YouTube because they had these
successful channels that they owned so
we could really do more insights so like
a big part of my job turned into being
going to like it was really cool I got
to travel the world which I'm very
grateful for but I go to like Zurich and
I talk to the engineers there and
expresses them like how I use the
platform there Michael how do you use
the platform like just discussing what
works best for creators and we're kind
of just like inside advocates for
creators which I really liked
do you feel that YouTube derived a lot
of value from having you guys or I think
they got a lot of great insight because
I they still I mean I think this is a
factor of the platform being so large
but they they still don't quite
understand it so I'm gonna I'm gonna say
that's entirely because we no longer
work there still have like labs of a
mind where there's people doing that's
what they do now is they'll have like
these lab channels but they're more like
six months long internship kind of
things or they'll give the like choose
different creators in different markets
and they'll give them access to the
YouTube space to like the strategist
audience development and they give them
like a budget to make content okay and
then that was kind of like the YouTube
Nextup program yeah so they basically
expanded the YouTube Nextup program that
you were yeah I was obviously a second
iteration of yeah it's really cool
second year and now they've made it
bigger or instead of it being like a
week-long thing it's a six month long
thing so that's what they do instead of
having house channels and one of the
issues that we ran into which is why we
kind of wanted independence from them I
mean I loved working at Google and I
really didn't feel like we were doing
good by being there and my favorite part
is that they literally had no say in our
content ever like they didn't even know
we made
video until was public hey so you made a
video today don't know why you had to
tarnish Google like we're science we're
not gonna like say terrible things low
risk yeah so that was really great and
they gave us so much freedom the issue
they were ran into though was part of
our job was to be able to speak to
creators and speak to brands about what
it's like being a creator and we didn't
get the full experience because we
couldn't do brand deals because are you
gonna do a brand deal with Google right
yeah for audible like no anyway so we
couldn't do that we couldn't do we
really wanted to make I'd this idea for
the what is now the curiosity box
I couldn't do that we couldn't like
write books we couldn't do live shows or
like I guess merchandise like he
couldn't sell merchandise we also
couldn't do YouTube originals our
YouTube red shows does that be
favoritism so we couldn't do any of
these things that we felt as creators we
should be able to do and again it would
give us the actual confidence and
knowledge to talk to creators if we
could do them so you felt a little
constrained we just loves of the
connection you know I think that the
issue was it's like you're living under
Popeyes yeah yeah I don't want to make
it on your own I don't want to disparage
Google coz it was a lovely place to work
and I'm very grateful for the
opportunities they gave us at Vsauce but
it felt like we wouldn't be able to grow
the business the way we wanted to with
them cuz they don't care about books
they don't care about TV shows like they
care about you making content on YouTube
but that's not what YouTube is anymore
YouTube is a part of the business not
your only business yeah so we felt like
to grow we needed to leave and they
agreed so they gave us full ownership of
the channels beginning to though that is
what I find cool
they just straight-up gave you the
channel they didn't sell it to you they
didn't like work out some sort of
contract they're just like alright it's
yours now right yeah and so suddenly you
didn't have to buy it
Wow cuz I know they did that with a
couple other channels like Indy mogul
yeah we're friends with those guys too
and they got their channel back which is
really cool yeah so now fresh little
baby straight out of graduating high
school fresh out of that house and
you're like alright a whole new world
time to make some content for ourselves
and to also survive on your own yeah
which I was very important to us like
it's scary having Google there's a
safety net was like very nice yeah
because again I didn't matter the videos
performed well or not they always took
it as a learning experience so how's it
gone it's gone really well I think I
mean
the issue is we were very it's one of
the reasons why we were able to make
content so infrequently and we could
really focus on quality rather than
quantity now we're we're struggling with
what that looks like but again that's
one of the reasons why we created things
like the Curiosity Box where that is
what helps pay for us to make content I
was a really good idea and all the stuff
that I've seen from it has been really
cool oh thank you um so good work on
that I feel like half my wardrobe is
from a city box
oh so many the shirts that I wear on our
quarter crew channel or like straight up
from that box yeah so so the Curiosity
Box let's talk about that for a second
do you have tiers or is it one price one
thing only one product just the Box they
can support early it's a quarterly box
there's no way to buy like we don't have
like a tee spring or whatever it's
called site like there's no Vsauce
merchandise besides the Curiosity box
and the whole reason for that box being
is I cuz I remember I was talking to
loot crate at VidCon like four or five
years ago yeah like hey we want to do
like a braid to be unbox loot crate
boxes on your channel and I just kind of
joking but I was like what if I make my
own box and unbox it on my channel talk
about it more so I've just met with them
and talked it was like I want to do a
Vsauce box filled with science stuff and
like Michael and Kevin were into the
idea so we did the first box with them
it was a holiday box in like 2015 and in
2015 no yes no holiday boxes and then we
did it then I didn't particularly like
working with them so we found another
company and worked with them for our
holiday box 2015 and they were great
because they really cared about the
quality which is what we cared about
blue crate was more focus on let's just
make a bunch of money and sell a
mediocre product yeah that didn't fly
for us yeah so we worked with them it
was great and from that we learned how
we could make this into something that
we could actually do quarterly because
we do spend a lot of time with it like
every product in there is designed by us
manufactured by us besides things like
the steam game in the book those are the
tubes we manufacture all those products
yeah
holy [ __ ] so we find unfortunately
american-made but we we manufacture man
Asia and then we package them all a lot
of work yeah so we like we actually just
finalized the design
or uh luckily this in the spoiler
because this box will be shipping by the
time this video comes out but we had
this really beautiful Mandelbrot poster
that Michael design so is right it's
really cool
Mandelbrot you know like the Mandelbrot
set know so it's this I mean maybe I do
but it's like Rigel well I don't I don't
know you have to see the poster okay I
can show you my phone after it looks
amazing but like it's one of the
products in the box that Michael design
and it looks incredible and the whole
point of the box is to give you that
vsauce experience at home so you can
actually touch it so instead of a do
online now guys it's a instead of a dog
do offline now it's a dog to do offline
now guys it's a dongle instead of a dog
no like one of the first boxes because i
bought like a whole year's subscription
of the boxes and we opened one of the
boxes on our channel last year the year
before and it was like it was like the
would be unboxed your box on our channel
but it was more so just being like hey
check out these cool things i have it
was like the the gyroscope yeah and what
was the the blue liquid thing we would
go through the pipe i can't think of the
name of it
oh we called it the vapor liquid we
still have remonstrate yeah it's on
display over there on the show you walk
in yeah yeah no that one's cool cuz he's
like you hold the bulb and the heat from
your hand increases the pressure and the
thing and that caught forces the liquid
to go through that yeah yeah I was
bubbling at the top yeah so the idea was
in again it like it is expensive it's
$50 a quarter but we didn't want to make
something cheap right everything is like
premium quality premium stuff and that's
same reason we don't sell like a t-shirt
on its own I mean now we have like a
curious box store you can buy older
products from their Alucard yeah but the
reason we don't make like a Vsauce shirt
this is a shirt like I'm feel like as
you guys wearing quarter stuff but like
to me know it happens it I want people
to like have something that they can
share with others and that also isn't
another reason the box it's called the
curiosity box and not the vsauce box is
because the hope is that people walking
on the street they'll see someone
wearing one of the shirts from it and
they have no idea who I am or what
Vsauce is they just really like the
curiosity box right because it's I think
when you create content on YouTube or
any business here and you see this in
traditional talent like okay yeah
they're an actor and actress but they
also have a makeup line or they also
sell like other stuff they do other
things and it's not called like Jessica
I was makeup it's some different name
right right and that was kind of the
intention with it is let's create a
product that can exist outside of
ourselves so if our channels do go away
cuz we don't control the algorithm on
YouTube who knows yeah we still have
something that exists that we can still
live off of that is still a great
experience for the consumer yeah that's
that's something we've gone over often
and fortunately we've been able to keep
things like relatively with inside the
corridor brand but at the same time
there's a lot of other ideas that we've
come across where I mean most of the
time we haven't pursued them because
it's just been a time factor but I think
that is really smart in the sense of
what you're saying where you're you're
creating something that can live on its
own and and like YouTube shut down the
other day yeah it's a very real thing
like it it could just go away now it's a
huge company backed by a huge company
backed by huge companies but you know
that said like yeah it's it's good to be
diversified in any creative what's
exactly it you have to diversify your
business like you
the old adage don't put all your eggs in
one basket yeah is especially true when
you don't control the basket yeah like
we don't control YouTube we have no idea
how the algorithm works or like what the
next ad pow-pow clip is gonna be know
who it's gonna affect so to me it's
really important that because we never
want to get in a place at least on
Vsauce where we have to make content to
make money yeah we make contact as we
love making videos and I want to keep
that going yeah so things like the Box
can exist to do that and the same reason
we don't and I feel bad cuz there you
guys a patreon same reason we don't do
patreon or things like that yes I don't
ever want to ask some from someone from
Wales and give them something in return
right so for me it's I want to give you
the best science box you're ever gonna
get it's 50 bucks I know it's a lot but
it's the best experience you'll ever
gonna get okay give me like $1 Barry and
I'll give you nothing I hear is it also
the Mainers I don't do patreon and this
is sorry oh you let rip it up do you my
supporter of you guys like I subscribe I
think the $3 a month tier or something
cool thank you I get the HD downloads
the 4k downloads nice but I don't want
to do it because I also don't want to
feel beholden to anyone cuz sometimes
like I'll be working a video doesn't
work out
don't make a video that month I don't
want people to feel like they're paying
me and I'm not delivering like I'm just
taking their money right yeah I never
want to feel like I have that kind of
commitment to a person Sheriff it's like
a stranger on the internet and I don't
want that responsibility
yeah so that's my main that's our main
reason that beats us for not doing that
kind of stuff and instead we know we can
deliver a product every quarter so
choose you two questions has the Box
been fundamental in allowing you to have
that creative freedom financially yes
second question do you think you because
this this goes back into your could you
survive the movies show YouTube
originals and YouTube premium two
separate products not everyone knows
that right now what you were saying
earlier about products existing on their
own do you feel that when YouTube did
YouTube premium or YouTube TV or YouTube
originals they should have branded those
differently to separate them in the mind
of the consumer yeah 100% I mean they
did a very big disservice when it was
originally came on was YouTube bread
there was just so many products within
that that is hard to spotlight all of
them it's like I paid for you to bread
which at the time was like $9.99 a month
I get google play music for free I get
add for YouTube I can offline videos I
can do background audio on videos and
also I get access to these YouTube red
shows right it's like okay but what if I
don't want all those things or like what
is YouTube red like YouTube Premium oh
is that just a higher tier of YouTube
like what does that allow me to access
can i upload larger videos like vimeo
plus or something like that it was it's
very complicated they've done a very
terrible job of explaining what each
product actually is and how it works and
the most important thing I think about
that is what you were telling me the
other day which is a they didn't explain
the product but also the premium the
money that comes from YouTube Premium
does the most to support the channels
you actually watch right yeah and so
it's not just this blanket of ad revenue
that's being like washed across the
algorithm and hope you get some via the
YouTube premium money actually goes to
the channels that you're watching and
that's actually a thing that was very
frustrating to me I remember talking to
YouTube about this during the ad
pocalypse
I was like why aren't you guys promoting
more that YouTube read at the time or
what it's called premium YouTube premium
actually that money goes to creators
because I feeling like the thing that
always sucks about now YouTube but
traditional media is that advertisers
have the say if a producers aren't gonna
pay to advertise on your show then you
don't have a show anymore right and if
advertisers aren't going to do the same
thing like don't want to be on your
content on YouTube then you don't have
content anymore because you need that
money to survive but what YouTube
premium allowed users to do is take that
power out of the hands of advertisers
and put it back into the hands of users
which is the same thing that's why HBO
exists and Netflix is yes yeah exactly
like it's by the fact that you pay for
it right and now you get to watch what
you want because you're the one paying
for it and that's what YouTube premium
does I watch court or digital great they
get some of my $10 a month subscription
goes to them right so now I'm actually
paying for these channels by watching
them and that to me made so much sense
and was such a missed opportunity for
YouTube to relate but again they didn't
want to promote it because they make the
majority the money from advertisers yeah
they don't want to piss off their
advertisers they want these both
products to exist together where I think
premium should just separate the best
product yeah like it's such a great ad
for YouTube is the best experience the
world the fact that I know that I'm
supporting my creators as I like is
great off lining videos is wonderful I
have the premium I've had YouTube bread
since almost since it began and it's
like my favorite thing because well
first off like the thing that affects me
most directly are the ads I don't really
like seeing ads who does right but you
know I don't want to use adblock and not
support my my favorite creators at the
same time so like most of my ET viewing
is on my TV and so I don't like sitting
through ads and there's no way to
install adblock even if I wanted to on
my TV but YouTube red was the easiest
way to get rid of those ads yeah and
it's just I've not been able to go back
well wouldn't it be great if just a
fraction of the people who use YouTube
out of like the billions of monthly
users that they have right if like a
hundred million people signed up for
YouTube red or YouTube premium it like
it's now twelve dollars a month what
should be ten percent of their total you
used your like that I wouldn't have to
rely on advertisers anymore yeah like it
wouldn't have to be ads supported right
and I that's the dream in my life is
like when YouTube is just supported by
instead of like dividing everything
because now they have like YouTube
members or
ever you can like support for $5.00 a
month an individual creator have you
seen that they do yeah on YouTube live
now - yeah you have like super chat yeah
so you can pay money but this is YouTube
members which is basically twitches
version it's twitch subscribe but on
YouTube where I can pay $4.99 a month
directly to this channel so that but
then there's also patreon then there's
also YouTube premium I always thought
that YouTube really messed up by not
buying patreon to be honest and just
turning that system into the YouTube
membership and thing that they have now
it's just so divided you know I think
that's a fear that we're gonna run into
is where people are supporting channels
via patreon or these memberships and
then I can have enough money now to like
support other channels right that's like
they should bundle them yeah actually
that's a point where we're getting to
now is there are more and more pay
subscription models Disney's working on
a huge one that's gonna come out next
year that you're after that's gonna take
all their stuff off every platform yeah
and I already have so many subscriptions
yeah there my dog has a subscription box
turning bad traditional cable it's yes
becoming just as expensive yeah
and that's I don't know what's gonna
happen at that point but people will
reach a point where they just I mean
everyone does this I I already reached
this point I started cutting
subscriptions yes I was like these are
expensive and I'm not really using them
yeah it actually reminds me on the side
having pornos this is not an endorsement
for barkbox
no it's not I'm ending my subscription
for the record is a what was it
subscriptions oh the saturation point
that I feel is gonna happen on YouTube
we're not only or gonna say about
subscriptions but cuz we both do these
things where it's like audible or
Skillshare you know Squarespace mhmmm
we're gonna hit a point where no one
wants to sign up anymore they've already
signed everything wanted to sign up and
that's a fear that I have actually I uh
yeah that's not advertising for a second
you see I really dislike
performance-based advertising and what I
mean by that for those at home is where
you the value of the ad that you're
promoting is paid by how many people
turn into subscribers
that product it'll be like oh we're
doing an audible.com good all about calm
slash your ROI size whether you click
through what's your CTR that kind of
stuff I hate cuz then they'll be like a
stable version we only got a thousand
subscriptions for this we were hoping
for like five thousand so if you want to
do it again with us that's fine but
we're gonna pay you infinitely less yeah
and I got you know the way that I do
advertising in my videos is that you're
paying for ad space it's like a
billboard on the side of the road yeah I
get it like my favorite is I was always
with Ford they spend like three billion
dollars a year advertising their cars
and guess what like 2% or 5% of people a
year buy a new car but what the point of
why they spend so much money is because
they want you to think Ford when you
think about a new car yeah it's it's
about keeping it in the mindset of
people so the way performance-based
advertising to me is never gonna work
because you like let's say make an
audible video twice a month or like once
a month you doing auto everybody's
watched your content knows about audible
now they either signed up or they didn't
because they don't care yeah so that
performance numbers always gonna go down
if you have to get a new brand of this
it's gonna keep going down it's never
gonna be this flat line of like oh we're
good we're fine cuz everyone now pays
for performance based advertising
instead of just like brand awareness
like for instance with the audible spots
that we do I like to do those because
it's just for me a really cool
opportunity to talk about a book that I
recently read or really liked or
listened to but um and I remember seeing
some comments being like you know what
Ren I finally got audible because you
finally convinced me I should do it it
had nothing to do with the book that I
was recommending I mean maybe it did but
it was mostly just like I talked about
it enough times like oh yeah you know
I'm gonna do it and I think they I don't
even know if they used our URL to do and
they just I had talked about enough
times with enough enthusiasm that
they're finally like okay yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna go for it right yeah that's
what actually that person found to be
interesting about it and that that
wouldn't have been reflected in the ROI
I guess of that particular spot it would
have because the only reason why that
matters because of all the other times I
talked about it well that's the thing
that they can't track when it comes to
this like performance based thing is
maybe I make a video on like oh go get
us website at squarespace.com and maybe
they do it the next day but since it
didn't click the link in my description
I don't get credit for that person
exactly yeah and that to me is very
frustrating and also I don't
like I don't know it's weird cause like
we're promoting these products but we
don't own a percentage of Squarespace or
of audible like we've no ownership in it
yet they're being like be our brand
spokesperson you sell the product for us
and we're gonna continually making money
off it cuz these are all
subscription-based services but you get
a one-time fee for selling your audience
so is the best is the best form of
advertisement one then that is more what
you're talking about earlier like with
which is similar to our philosophy but
just Casey's philosophy which is the
brand is the hero and they make
something possible but they don't get in
the way yeah like they are the reason
this exists and that to me is the best
it's goodwill I mean I did that with
Lowe's for my home alone video where at
the beginning it says like vsauce3 and
Lowe's present and then we've a behind
the scenes on their channel but they're
not in the video elsewhere it's because
of them that we got to make this really
great experience and I think viewers
they care about your content and care
about you then feel appreciative to like
the brand because they let this happen
right and yeah yeah there are the hero
the like oh you're a good guy you made
you let Jake make this dream project
yeah it's not like come over to my side
and make as I want you to make so uh
blue aprons really great everyone goes
sign up to blue apron you got to do it
right now is 20% off you use blue apron
comm slash vsauce3 now let me tell you
about my video it's like no cuz I'm
gonna stop listening because I just had
to listen to an ad so I don't care what
you have to say anymore it's like you
thing you bring that up on a podcast
because that is like the quintessential
form of advertisement but I guess I
think makes sense podcast a little bit
different YouTube videos don't feel the
same yet like it is so weird to me
because you watch television
you'll get served with three-minute ad
breaks every like five minutes but on
YouTube if you get anything over like a
15 or 30 second ad you like whoa
television you watch what like 20
minutes
yeah it's 20 sorry it's let me do the
math here 16 minutes yeah
so you have this whole thing the words
it's this weird division that I don't
really understand where you know I think
that's just has to do with the fact that
like YouTube is so new that people
haven't figured out marketing exactly is
that YouTube I mean YouTube is new
relative to TV the issue is that
advertisers aren't spending enough money
on YouTube yet
in terms of like that CPM that we get
those like views that we get when people
watch an ad before a video aren't high
enough and I think that will change over
time where we don't have to rely on
doing brand deals my dream or that's one
of them again the reason we have the
Curiosity boxes so we hopefully when it
gets big enough never have to do a brand
deal ever again unless it's something
cool like I got to do brand deals but
it's like oh we're gonna give you Paul
Rudd like dope I'll do that dude I
remember that it wasn't tell us the
video be better great but if it's just
me at the end being like go sign up for
this I'd rather not do it but sometimes
you have to because you just have a
business that you have to run after me
to do it right but I think that YouTube
advertising needs to get to the point
where it mirrors TV advertising where
you're doing better call Saul okay great
I gotta pay $100,000 to run my Home
Depot AD during the ad break that are
mindshare yeah yeah but they need that
stuff for us so it's like instead of $2
per ad click it's like no no no it's $20
you got a million views on it and out of
those million let's say a hundred
thousand were monetized at $20 per CPM
all right cool I can now make a living
off this and not have to worry about
anything else and but it puts you in
this weird place on YouTube where you do
need to create other ways of making
money be it brand deals or making
t-shirts and selling stuff yeah I mean
that's as frustrated that yeah it is
that's that's been something that we've
struggled with as well like that's why I
brought up the Curiosity Box I wanted to
talk about that because that's
constantly something we're striving to
do is how can we how can we come become
independent mm-hmm
completely from ads 100% it's it's a
long road but I think for you guys get
here eventually your focus is always on
quality content yeah one of things I
really respect about the videos that you
make and you know I said this guy's to
you yesterday but like you know I would
watch your videos before I started
making the videos that I do now I would
like watch your guys kind of like oh I
want to make something that looks that
good like remember what my favorites is
actually the portal video that you did I
believe portal trick shots did you drink
that one I did yeah yeah yeah like that
one I remember just be like this is so
incredible like it's so smart it was so
clever I was like I want to make
something that good like that clever and
so I get inspiration from you guys just
kicking butt but sorry back to the
original topic for sirs dropping I mean
you can I'm okay
but so it is this quality focus over
this quantity focus yeah is that
rewarded on YouTube I don't think so but
I don't think so what if you know we had
these ancillary ways of making money so
you could just focus on quality and
that's what we're trying to build it
Vsauce right is let's create these other
avenues be at the curiosity box maybe
it's like Vsauce productions downline
these other things that allow us to make
the best quality content on YouTube
without having to sacrifice that to be
like well we just need to keep making
videos cuz you need money right
no I just want to make things that I
want to make I'm very arrogant about it
but I'm fine with that cuz I make these
things cuz I want to make them and I'm
really happy that people enjoy them but
at end of day that we make things cuz
we're passionate about it
mm-hmm it's not like doing YouTube isn't
an easy job even the people who looks
easy like you know you can look at like
a Jake Paul will say but like I will say
I might not that's not easy I might not
like the content that he grates might
not be for me but this man has an empire
like a business that he had to build
himself yeah and it's like difficult to
do even the like PewDiePie's of the
world it's like oh these like life's you
make video no they're running a whole
entire business yeah and they happen to
also be the business like it's difficult
um I think people really uh I guess
underscore or under appreciate how much
work and talent is involved with
seemingly untalented but yeah I feel
like a lot of people don't really
appreciate how much work and talent
someone like PewDiePie has yeah or like
is required to run a channel like what
PDP that's just miss any of that stuff
which is why again if the content isn't
for me that's fine but I still think
that these folks that are successful on
YouTube obviously are very smart when it
comes to how they operate their business
or they wouldn't be successful when you
first came on the coridor crew channel
Rhett and ran had mentioned this earlier
but something was going on in your life
at that point something pretty serious
you'd cancer yes yeah I want to hear
about this I have some questions that
I'd like to ask you about
got some questions cancer you don't know
about this what kind of cancer was it so
is the sarcoma which is a soft tissue
cancer and it's very rare I guess
there's only like 2,000 cases a year or
so okay in the entire world yeah so like
seven billion people in the entire world
mm-hmm and there's a cure for it no
there's no cure for cancer I'm sorry
well yeah those treatments yeah
there's no cure so basically it was very
inopportune timing I mean I never his
opportunity s boy I really get cancer
today anyway so I had just moved to LA
like I moved here October 2015 and then
in November of 2015 I got diagnosed with
it because I had this lump on my shin
and I soon was just a bump like I hit
something and it kept getting bigger so
I finally went to a doctor the first
doctor said that's probably just like a
cyst or something benign it's not a big
deal I was like okay I went to another
doctor said the same thing but he was
like you know what we'll just remove it
and we'll test it and see what it is
right now cool let's do that so I had a
minor operation they cut it open and I
even like instagrammed a photo of the
tumor yeah yeah oh whatever then a week
later I get a call and it's like hey so
we got the results back and you have
cancer it's sarcoma Bobo so I so go dang
ok so I went to cedars-sinai here in Los
Angeles because they had a dude who was
well versed and sarcomas and he kind of
went through with me and basically they
gave me two options there was the
optimal idea in their minds that would
make it so I wouldn't get it again which
was to cut off my leg uh and I was like
what's the second option was behind door
number two okay door number two was that
because the issue of is on my shin so
when you do have a cancer earlier than
they need to cut it out if they can't
cut it out they need a wide area you may
believe it cuz just one cells all it
takes for it to propagate again and
spread yeah so they couldn't get very
deep because I was riding my shin bone
so that's why they label let's just cut
off your leg and we'll know that we got
it so I was like wow let's just not do
that one yet so they I went in for an
operation in December and I was in the
hospital for a week and they basically
just cut open my leg I have photos of it
it's gross
they like took out this wide area of my
leg and the hole was so big that they to
fill it with something so they went in
and they cut open the side of my leg and
took the bottom part of my calf muscle
and flip that over
put that on the top to fill the hole and
then they took a skin graft for my hip
and put that on top of it there Wow um
and it's very difficult was in the
hospital for a week which isn't too long
but I couldn't we not stop like you're
in yeah I was in a bed for we I couldn't
move you didn't do anything like they
had a nurse had to come in to like wash
me and all those things like I had to
pee in a bucket basically right that I
would then put on my table a nurse would
come in and like empty it and bring it
back to me all right nurse is great they
are great but it's very it was very
difficult and then after that I was able
to go home after a week like I think the
day before Christmas I can I went home
and I just I still couldn't move so I
was very difficult because like my
bedroom was on the bottom floor but
everything goes on top floor so I'd like
get on my butt and scoot down the stairs
Wow and I had to do physical therapy for
a month and then I started after my leg
was healed enough I did go back to the
hospital every week to check out my leg
because I had a tube coming out of it so
blood would come out so I wouldn't get
blood clots my leg
yeah and I did that and then ended
January I started doing radiation
therapy for three months so every day
Monday through Friday I'd go to the
Cancer Center and do radiation treatment
can you describe exactly what that is
though so it's like I remember you
getting like tattooed dots yeah so they
would it has to be at a very certain
location on your leg or wherever the
treatment needs to be delivered so I
remember going in there like do you mind
if we give you tattoos it's like I don't
care so they had to do these instead of
drawing tracking dots every time a my
leg they just tattooed the tracking dots
onto where they had to align the
radiation machine right so they tattooed
these that's still there on my shin do
that and then yeah I would sit in and be
about fifteen to thirty minutes
that was funny cuz like you know you get
an x-ray they always leave the room
something like it's this giant machine
that I'm like laying in and everyone
leaves the room and it's like dimly lit
and they always have like Enya playing
and there's a radiation treatment to me
every single day and it was it was
difficult because it's like it zaps you
takes out your energy but also you know
it the funny thing about radiation
therapy is that eventually generally it
will give you cancer so like if I get
cancer again it's not going to be
because my sarcomas back it's gonna
because I got cancer because the
radiation machine but what it does is it
it basically just kills everything so
your skin like starts peeling and
blister layer these giant gross blisters
on my leg like all three months and
they're like super painful huh
you have to do it because you don't want
to die yeah so so like this this
radiation machine was it like this big
articulating arm yeah with like cameras
on it to identify where the does itself
yep and it would how big was like the
actual radiation stream from it was like
it was it like a pinprick sized knee
would just kind of like you know move
around or is it just blasting the entire
area without moving though it's
relatively pointed so like it knows
where it's going it moves around the leg
okay um it shoots radiation at you can
you see it no okay but I think that's
that was always so strange to me is that
like it's this thing that I can I can't
feel it while it's happening afterwards
once it's done like then you start
feeling the effects of the radiation
which what makes radiation poisoning and
stuff so scary to me it's like it's a
thing that you can't see that you don't
know that's there and then when you do
it's too late
yeah that's I just learned today that
people that get leukemia often it's
because of radiation mm-hmm didn't know
that oh well if you paid more attention
and could you saw the movies Mad Max
will you talk about that my snarky then
alright thank you
but yeah so there was a very interesting
time of my life because I'm sorry you go
I mean yeah so I'm I'm just kind of
curious about the experience of having
cancer cuz most people just know that
having cancer sucks yeah like just kind
of generally like alright it sucks and I
might die those are like the two main
things people know so you're saying it
zaps your energy now like how how does
that work so it's like you're like oh
I'm having a good day at coffee I went
in had radiation and then now I'm just
tired
yeah is that is it how media is that is
that just kind of like an ongoing thing
throughout the course of the months
you're doing radiation yeah it was like
only for the first few hours after the
treatment no most of the day and I think
a lot of it too is if you've ever
experienced like depression where you
just you have no motivation to do
anything like you want to but like you
just can't get your mind to agree to it
like your body's just it feels like your
body's separate than your mind like yeah
I would be like I want to do these
things but I just physically can't
because I have no energy I have no
excitement I have like no motivation to
do anything so I would do because my
points from 115 everyday so I would do
all of my me
and stuff in the morning because after
radiation I just couldn't do anything
I'm like go home lay on the couch and
just like sit there and do nothing right
I ordered a lot of delivery racked up a
lot of post maid's bills um so yeah that
was really difficult because it was
frustrating to me because I I don't like
being stationary I like to always do
things yeah it's always be working it's
why I like did two jobs at once in New
York and LA like I just always want to
do things yeah so I was very frustrating
to me because I was basically like
imprisoned in my own body and I couldn't
do anything and then everyday with the
deafening like for the entire year like
all of 2016 up until the end of it when
they finally told me that like I was
cancer free or had been in remission
should I say I have like everyday just
like well I could die today like how I
felt every single day it was this
constant thing that I had but then he
gets to the point really I'm fine with
it now like I could die so as a weird
head space to be in but I am happy that
I got cancer to be honest like I sounds
weird but I think I imagine because it
gave you a new perspective on life right
yeah I've become a lot more open-minded
towards things like I used to be very
much like oh I don't like that so I'm
not gonna experience it not like oh I
want to experience this to see if I like
it cuz I don't know I think I remember
you saying wasn't you having cancer and
then going into remission like basically
recovering from that isn't that why you
took the the beam job in New York on top
of basically starting out a new YouTube
not a youtube new youtube channel but a
recently independent channel so now
you're working in two states and that
was like you're like you know what I've
had enough I'm gonna or not it's not
that you had enough you're like I want
to have more now I want to be able to do
everything that I can
yeah well I felt like I didn't do as
much as I could have done for like a
whole year because I was just like da
nerd like scared or whatever so I wanted
to make up for that so say oh this is
great
now I can have like another job I can do
more things I can prove in a large part
of Ryan took that job was to prove to
myself that I could do something else I
wanted to see if I wasn't just like a
one-trick pony I mean I don't know the
answer to that yet still but that was
part of it yeah apartment was the cancer
thing it was just like I'm here for such
a short amount of time regardless of if
I like get cancer again or just in
general mm-hmm and I want to do as much
as I can that's always been important to
me is like doing more than you think is
possible and pushing yourself and you
made a video when you did have cancer
like you made a full vsauce3 video
can can you just kind of briefly explain
what it's like making a video like
production schedule wise it was very
difficult so that video actually I had
written like I plan to make it in
December of 2015 then all the stuff
happened I delete it and then I just had
no energy or motivation to make it and I
felt bad cause like I'm gonna be like in
a chair and then as time went on like I
think it was about five or six months
since my last video I felt very
self-conscious like oh I've been making
people wait for so long like what if
it's not good I move so I have to be
stationary the entire time like it's
gonna be really dumb or people gonna be
upset and eventually I just like forced
myself to do but we had to do it we can
only film before I went to radiation
therapy so we fit like the longest video
it ever took me to make like even the
mad max idiot took me three and a half
days to film this one took me like a
week to film and we I just have to look
exactly the same every single day and we
were just Eric would come over who does
all our V effects in cinematography I'm
Vsauce
and we would just film like in the
mornings for a whole week and then I
would like sit in my little chair and
like edit it and then just do everything
that way but it was difficult that's why
the whole video so it's it's called like
for logical paradoxes I think yeah
there's my next video
and in the entire video I'm sitting down
like I'm in my Eames chair like I never
move out of the Eames chair cuz I just
couldn't walk anywhere now didn't you
acknowledge in the video that you had
cancer yeah and that's why you weren't
gonna be moving much cuz I want to know
in fact that like this is why I thought
was a pretty good excuse for why I've
been gone for like six months I feel
like having cancer is a good enough
excuse for practically anything so it
was interesting two questions on that
number one when did they tell you okay
it's in remission or you're cancer-free
like at what point did that happen after
that was in December of 2016 so remember
that very well because I'd never really
like cried or anything about my lot in
life I was like well this is just what I
have to deal with and I'll deal with it
yeah I remember going to the doctor and
I did because I for a while now
basically when I had I was going through
treatment I had to go and like everyday
and then it turned into after we
finished radiation I would go in once a
month and do scans then I was every
three months then there's every six
months and now it's once a year starting
this year so I had done my like three
whatever check up and they came in to
tell me the test was also like there's
no signs of anything like everything
looks really great like your cancer is
in remission never be like what was that
one it was like I'm sorry it was like my
cancer free and there's a gap I was like
okay cool
well good see you doctor I gotta go I'm
really going to the parking garage or
the Cancer Center just sitting in my car
and it's like crying yeah like this huge
weight had been lifted from me
right so I've literally thought every
single day that I was gonna die like I
already planned out what my last video
was going to be and like I found out how
the music for it yeah and like what it
would look like and the topics that I
would talk about and like I had this
whole entire it'd be called a life by
Jai Grover like then the title of the
video to be called a life and just be
about like what it means to like be
alive and all these things and that
would end with this very nice montage of
like my favorite moments from like
videos that I've made or like videos
I've been with my friends and be set to
this song by m83 so I have to like try
and get a license from them this whole
thing playing out you'd be gone at that
point so you could just post it yeah no
one care set it in first I think I had
the whole schedule like I would make it
like while I was in the hospital bed
like I'd start filming it now and then
like as I got worse and worse it would
like progressed through that yeah and
then like I would basically ask like
Michael or something to make it public
like once I had died like then make the
video public Wow so this whole entire
plan in my head of like what my final
video would be because I thought that I
would die at any moment so when he told
me that I potentially wouldn't die at
any moment I was like it just I don't
know
it just like rushed over me and I just
sat in my car in this like garage in Los
Angeles and just like cried for 20
minutes of course you did um that's
super powerful stuff and that was like
the first time that like I actually I
cried during the whole process yeah but
it's a lot to deal with man I think the
things that always stuck out to me the
most was when I went in for the surgery
the big one
and I remember filling all the paperwork
and they asked me like who had power of
attorney basically like if you don't
wake up from surgery like who has the
authority to pull the plug or not right
I was like oh that's the thing that I've
never considered yeah and like my
girlfriend at the time was there I was
like hey would you mind like doing this
for me and I had like lay out the rules
like okay so if Ike I'm in a coma for
this long like then you can pull the
plug if Ike this head it's like all this
stuff and I'd like write a will which I
had never considered ever after right
now cuz I was in my 20s like what the
hell hmm
so I was all like very weird to me and
very made it more real I think I was
like
have your affairs in order yeah but I'm
just going in for surgery right like I'm
gonna be fine
maybe like we probably and then the
thing like you go to sleep and then you
wait you're like okay well hopefully I
wake up again right so strange yeah yeah
I dealt with that I lost both my parents
to cancer so I'm intimately familiar
with some of the things you're going
over but my second question do you think
there was anything what do you think
caused it do you think there was any
particular thing or do you think it was
just so as far as I know scientifically
sarcomas are just mutations it's not
predisposed by like if my parents had it
like I'm not more likely to get it or
less likely to get it and has nothing to
do with like your diet you know it's not
like a lung cancer like how smoking
could help that it's just a random
mutation it's just bad luck yeah it just
happened do you know exactly what kind
of sarcoma it is no I know there's
different ones
I don't here's the thing when I member
they were telling about it I was like
not paying attention I'm just like oh my
gosh I have cancer yeah like oh it says
whatever sarcoma I like the thing I do
remember is them telling me that it was
like because they do it by like grades
or something
this was like a grade three it was like
the most aggressive kind oh it was a
grade three yeah yeah so it was really
aggressive not good that's why they're
very good about it because yeah pretty
much after that point it goes to the
rest of your body and yes that's again
why they wanted to cut off my leg
because they're like if just one cell
gets in your bloodstream
yep like it's gonna go everywhere in
your body yeah cuz since it loves soft
tissues like what is your entire chest
it's soft tissue Organa she's um like
what is your brain like it would just
spread and throughout my entire body
that's what they would keep that's why I
did go every single week and like do
tests you had to get my blood drawn
every single day like all this stuff
just to make sure like it didn't spread
anywhere but yeah they were very so
that's the thing I paid attention it was
like 'wait grade three what does that
mean and I like look it up and it's like
chance of survival is like ten percent
like yeah okay that's not great yes it
was like it was pretty heavy so I didn't
really pay attention to too much I was
just like okay I'm just gonna do
whatever they tell me to do but I lucked
out I mean luckily we caught it early I
didn't have to do chemotherapy or any of
that kind of stuff is just radiation
therapy yeah
so I mean it worked out well I still you
know I'm going in December to do another
scan and we'll see but feel good good
thank you scrap yeah
thank you well that's that's I'm glad
dude that's inspirational to see like
that you've come back you're you're
you've learned from it and you're moving
forward with that knowledge yeah I mean
like I said weirdly it was great to have
I'm happy I survived it but like it
really put into perspective like what
was important to me and the things I
wanted to focus on and really even
though I feel like I've always been a
relatively driven person it really amped
up what I want to do in my life that's a
perfect segue because I was just about
to ask you what is your ideal Sunday
ideal creative format like I think you
already harp upon it earlier but just
just if you could do any format mm-hmm
what would it be uh stop-motion I'd love
to make a stop-motion really animated
children's film really yeah that's my
dream stop-motions it a lot of work it
is done spot that motion yeah you said a
show called fact surgery on vsauce3
where would be I remember that yes it'd
be like do a Playstation 3 and original
and tender like disassembling themselves
and their be facts inside of them and I
made that because I love the art form I
wasn't with the facts I stopped making
it because people only care about the
facts and like no but it's not the art
so stop-motion is is what I would love
to do I've always I mean if I can make
more of could you try the movies I'd
love to do one that is just stop-motion
like I have a Miyazaki 30ms
style I mean we have to get a higher
budget but okay it might be dreams of
stop-motion oh yeah okay but I would
love to I would love to make a
stop-motion film I think we watch what
uh Lika Lika Lika Lika la ika lekha
named after the Russian space dog
anyway okay so they make Coraline they
made collagen strings yeah okay yeah
like they I would if you're watching
this someone who works there I would
love to go like just tour the studios in
Oregon like they are incredible super
cool and that's my dream is to make
because it's art and I'm not an artist
but I would love to try and be one and I
want to do a stop-motion film
awesome so there you go great great
answer I didn't expect that I didn't
either
Wow Wow this guy's a wild card ladies
and gentlemen well that's it we did it
we did it first episode first episode is
complete what core cast do I really want
to say thank you for coming on and and
of course in supporting this endeavor
that we're doing because of course I'm
not I'm not gonna name names but I
emailed some other people and they were
like yeah we're busy
they used the B word they told me they
were busy so here's the thing about
being busy you can always make time if
something's important to you exactly
that's how I feel about it relationships
work
yeah it's important to you you can make
time and do it sure there's 24 hours of
the day that's a lot you don't sleep
thanks for being here man all right
thanks for having me I love you guys if
you guys liked what you saw definitely
consider checking out some of our other
episodes we even have cut downs on the
same channel if you guys don't have time
to watch a full episode but we've got
special guests we've got great
conversations we're gonna be doing this
every week so consider subscribing see
you around